vous savez comme sénat entendent pas
tout
elle s'appelle pauline rambo de barallon
mais appelez là prb à 30 ans la
chanteuse et elle affiche pour la
première fois au printemps de bourges
tout autour de moi moi le printemps de
bourges ça a été une aventure voilà
familiale personnelle donc évidemment
revenir jouer à la maison de la culture
pour voilà pour défendre cet album c'est
c'est très fort en émotion pour moi
cette barbara fougueuse plainte et de
rap et d'électro et sélectionné aux
inouï en 2020 les influences de la plume
acérée de pr2 besson diverses ce qui
m'intéresse dans ma musique c'est de
raconter des histoires c'est de
travailler ses émotions et c'est vrai
que je crois que ces différents genres
musicaux en tout cas d'essayer de les
mélanger ça apporte ça c'est à dire
parfois ggd j'ai des textes qui peuvent
être plein d'emphase et au contraire
j'aime bien les confronter à un truc
plus rugueux de 2,2 de musique techno et
je crois que c'est ça c'est ça que je
trouve assez excitant
des paroles et des mélodies qui restent
dans la tête
ce qu'il en soit c'est comme si bien
comme ça sa chanson métavers sonne comme
un hymne queer qui déconstruit les
normes de genre cette chanson elle est
partie de quelque chose de tout petit et
ça commence en disant voilà trois fois
par jour on me prend pour un garçon et
ça ne me dérange pas c'est les démange
là où ça fait mal en fait au fond cette
chanson elle parle de ça et ensuite ce
qu'elle dit juste c'est est ce qu'on a
besoin de nommer les choses et en même
temps j'en fais une chanson c'est avec
une clarinette que pauline fait ses
premiers pas d'artiste à bourges
c'est la même clarinette ont plus que
depuis mes 8 ans donc c'est vraiment ma
ouais elle est là ces mares malraux mais
c'est ma soeur quoi
son premier album rayons gamma la
chanteuse a mis cinq ans à le composer
une artiste qui prend son temps mais qui
se donne surtout entièrement sur la
scène